Well, the HBO
series The
Gilded Age is in its second season
and tells the story of New York City's
high society during the late 1800s.
Here's a look at the new season.
New York
is where society puts itself on display.
The leaders meet each other
and their children call each other.
The old guard thinks they can keep out
the new people with impunity,
but nothing stays the same forever.
I don't just want a husband, Tom.
Data is rich.
He's even handsome.
What more could a girl ask for?
It's a great show.
It's in the middle of its second season.
Joining us now, members
of the cast of the Gilded Age,
Morgan Spector, Christine Baranski,
Cynthia Nixon, Diddy Benton,
Carrie Coon and Louise Jacobson.
Guys, thanks so much for joining us.
I get to throw in a second.
You seem to actually like one another
quite a bit.
Is that a fair assessment?
What's not to like?
Right.
We really love each other just.
To feed our kids.
I think that.
The interplay Peter just does.
How do you think the theater
kid, the Broadway experience?
Your guys resumés are pretty remarkable
plays into this show,
specifically this cast.
I mean, anybody who's worked on the
stage for a while,
eventually you do a course of playing,
you know, night after night shows a week.
And of course, you know,
okay, this is my world.
This is how I speak,
this is how I carry myself.
And I think a lot of us have just real
theater training and chops.
So. Yeah.
And the sense of ensemble.
Yeah.
Everybody is working up
about telling the story and not about,
you know, standing out in a room.
Throwing the ball.
That's right. You mentioned the costumes.
The esthetics of fashion
is not my specialty,
but you can't possibly
ignore the extraordinary costumes,
how they all come together.
The set is also unbelievable.
But Morgan, the characters as well,
some of them are directly
at a adaptation's from real people.
Some of them are
akin to people
or have through and through.
How do you prepare for that,
knowing that there's a historic parallel
to who you're playing?
The the the, the, the real sort of analog
that I was given
initially with Jay Gould.
So I,
I read a bunch about him
and he's a he's
a really fascinating character.
I mean, a lot of these people,
this sort of American myth that you can,
you know,
you can pull yourself up
by your bootstraps
or you can sort of turn your,
you know, the rags to riches stories.
And these guys really were
that, you know, these
these were these were tough.
These were hard, man.
But it's such a family man.
And he, you know, like to ten is orchids.
But yes.
And he was so he had that duality of of
of being sort of truly
ruthless in business,
but loving and tender
in his domestic life.
I think what's fascinating to me is
you guys are able to thread together
the dynamics of race and class and gender
and labor disputes, things
that are obviously still very much issues
today.
It's subtle, it's nuanced
and it
it doesn't feel like
a blunt, in-your-face. This is the issue.
You realize that it's all together
threaded in that time period.
I think Julian Fellowes really knows
his audience.
I think he knows that
they want to be entertained.
They're coming for the costumes.
They're coming for The Real Housewives,
you know, style disputes.
And he's also then able to enter the time
period obliquely and sort of
bring in these other factors
that were sort of bubbling
under the surface.
You know, we're not
we're not dealing
with the complexity of the,
you know, economic disparity necessarily.
But he is sort of
tiptoeing into all those worlds.
So people are there.
The awareness is always there.
Right.
I would say to follow up on that, he's
really wonderful
at using human stories
that are quite personal to reveal
and deal with bigger themes.
And and Shoni
Warfield and Erica Dunbar
were really instrumental
in being able
to create that nuance
in the world that Peggy moves through.
We were really able to collaborate
with Julian in just adding those textures
so that
they don't feel
quite like icing on the world, but still
actually get to be rooted in their own
rich internal lives.
And so it was special to get to kind of
alchemy is what that could be.
There's a real there's a real wit.
I think, to cutting from Peggy
being in mortal danger
to, you know,
this is the soup going to be delivered
without spilling.
And I think there's a
there's a temptation to see this
as like two separate storylines.
But actually,
I think
when you go from one to the other,
you see,
oh, this is
this is what privileges,
this is what wealth is.
It creates a world
where the stakes
are just absurd
as opposed to life and death.
It's a
such a fascinating period,
but it's also so like our own.
It's there's a new class of people.
Then it was industrial revolution money.
Now it's tech money
just bubbling up from, you know, from
seemingly from nowhere
and challenging the status quo
and so much disposable income.
This is sort of a grotesque way
African-Americans use striving
for equality and immigrants
facing prejudice and maybe competition
as they saw it with African-Americans and
women trying to push the envelope and
trying to have the right to vote,
much less work or even have careers.
It's certainly is
about the fear
that certain people
certainly my character
feels about a world that is in,
you know, endangered
and dangerous, being lost forever
and her sense of values
and her place in the world
and her concern for her niece
and her sense of
anger that that
a whole societal structure is crumbling.
She looks across
the street and sees a Trump Tower.
You know, she's facing what is this?
Who who are these people?
They're not our people.
They care more about money
and showing off money.
So it's a
it's about a world in transition.
And I think we're living in a world
in transition now.
Some of you have been on massive
hit HBO shows before.
Some of you have amazing resumes.
But this is the first major HBO hit.
Mm hmm.
I wonder if that informs
the approach is the experience
to those that have the
ability to talk to those
who have who haven't.
If that plays any role at all.
For me, it's been so special.
I think
when I originally got cast in this,
I didn't know how much
how much like black audiences
would feel seen
or or care about this show and
walking around Brooklyn
like I mostly get stopped by black women
and it's so special
because they're like, Oh my God,
Like it's us.
Like they really it's really us.
And it feels
it's just more special than I expected it
to be that, but it just feels so claimed.
I also get stopped by black women.
They all recognize Bertha too.
I wanted this to.
We really stand about you and it's
done.
The show really is extraordinary.
Costumes, the set,
the acting, the writing.
I really appreciate you guys coming in.
Thank you so much.
Pleasure to be here. Thank you.